but let's make an important Point you're
talking about a quality equaling respect
the way you get respect as a woman is by
being feminine there's nothing we can be
equal and very very different I'm not
saying that when there's not equality
but you've confused equality with the
same you can be equal with complete
different things you can have a bishop
and a knight on a chessboard they're
equal in terms of points but they do
different things right a woman can have
equal respect to a man if she is very
good at being a woman then a man gets
respect for being very good at being a
man when a woman decides she wants to
act like a man or a man wants act like a
woman that's where all gets [__] up
the whole thing it's not the same men
and women are good at different things
we have different strengths different
weaknesses there's nothing wrong with
accepting that there's nothing wrong
with saying I'm a woman I'm good at X
he's a man he's good at why then we work
together as a team we have a beautiful
family we're happy forever it's only
confused where you have women who sit
and go no because in the name of
equality we can fight and work there's
no [__] women on the front line in
Ukraine that is silent [__]